StStéphanie, Michel David Lucas
FeFernandez, bonsoir.
(E(Ensemble): bonsoir.
- - La question qui était poséeà
MoMonsieur Legault, est-ce que a
étété utile le couvre-feu?
vovoici sa réponse.
- - La bonne nouvelle,
çaça veut dire que les mesures
ququ'on a mises en place,
ququi étaient dures,
àà l la fin décembre,
totous ces sacrifices-là
quque les Québécois ont faits,
çaça a mené à u un résultat,
acactuellement, sur le nombre
d'd'infection et, on l'espèrere,
bibientôt t sur le nombre
d'd'hospitalisations.
- - Bon, je vous soumets que
aiailleurs, il n'y a pas eu de
cocouvre-feu. L'école était prée
dede rouvrir en Ontario lundi. t
leles chiffres aussi à N New Yok
babaissent. On s'aperçoit, on
sosouhaite que ce soit le piqué.
StStéphanie, qu'avez-vous pensée
cecette e annonce?
- - Je pense qu'on peut se réjor
quque les écoles ouvrent. Il y
avavait presque unanimité de la
papart des pédiatres: des
spspécialistes qui disent écoute
..... les enfants doivent allerà
l'l'école... ça ne sont pas les
mmêmemes sont à l la maison. Ilt
ququestion de la santé mentale.
LeLes gens ont beaucoup souffert
dedepuis le début de la pandémie
etet on ne veut pas que ça crée
unune génération COVID qui va êe
enencore plus sacrifiée. Je pene
quque une bonne chose. Par cont,
onon aurait pu espérer que
dadavantages soit fait du côtéte
lala vaccination. Le quartier
MoMontréal où ça traînene de la
papatte. On aurait pu espérer qe
popourquoi pas des masques à 9 5
popour les enseignants ça pouvat
leles rassurer?
- - excusez-moi, mais vous (des
mamasques. On a conspué Docteur
ArArruda en disant que les masqe
N9N95 n'étaient pas utiles. Elle
esest à 9 95, toute la science s
didit que ce n'est pas plus
sésécuritaire dans un contexte
d'd'une école par exemple. Ce
n'n'est pas plus sécuritaire. E-
cece que ce n'est pas nous, qui
fafaisons des lubies parfois?
- - peut-êtrtre, mais ça aurait
pepeut-êêtrtre sécurisé les
prprofesseurs, et eux sont peut-
êêtrtre plus à r risque que les
élélèveves d'avoir des
cocomplications. Je ne remets ps
enen question le point de vu de
DoDocteur Boileau qui connaîtt
cecertainement plus que moi en
mamatièrere de sécurité et de sé
pupublique. Mais aussi du coût e
lala ventilation, ce n'est pas
didire qu'il a des problèmemes r
dadans les écoles. Avec la
momoisissure, ça fait des années
ququ'on en parle. Le dernier, on
auaurait peut-êtrtre pu prendree
tataureau par les cornes pendant
quque les écoles étaient vident.
C'C'est quand mêmeme dommage ene
dede questions à s savoir la qué
dede l'air sera bonne.
- - Pour les écoles, Stéphanie
HoHoude, il devait êtrtre d'acc,
c'c'était exigé par les pédiatr,
onon ne peut pas se permettre de
gagarder nos enfants plus
lolongtemps à l la maison. De la
fofolie.
- - Évidemment. Quand on regarde
leles avantages, il semble évidt
quque les besoins de socialisatn
dede scolarisation des enfants
l'l'emportent largement sur le
ririsque ça peut poser.
MaMaintenant, les discours songt
àà p propos des masques mais aui
àà p propos de l'école. Par
exexemple, pendant tout l'autom,
nonous disait, les écoles sont
dedevenues un des principaux
fofoyers d'éclosion. Le Docteur
BoBoileau nous dit, non, les
écécoles ne sont que le reflet e
lala contagion communautaire.
C'C'est peut-êtrtre vrai maintet
quque Omicron a remplacé Deltan,
etet bien honnêtetement, c'est
didifficile de savoir quelle est
lala certitude scientifique qu'n
pepeut avoir. Le couvre-feu, par
exexemple, la logique nous dit e
cocouvre-feu diminue les contac.
IlIl n'y a jamais eu d'étude qua
dédémontré que ça diminuait les
leles hospitalisations. Les étus
enen Europe en 2020 où nous
exexpliquait que oui, le nombree
cocontacts pouvait diminuer de 0
àà 3 30 %. On n'a jamais fait
l'l'adéquation certaine avec les
hohospitalisations ou les décès.
EnEncore là, , je pense que c'ee
didiscours général qui commenceà
chchanger. Je ne sais pas si vos
avavez remarqué, à p peu prèss
pepersonne afin de diminuer nos
cocontacts. On est dans une aute
phphase. Faux avec nez, mais on
rerecommence à r rouvrir. Monsir
LeLegault, la nouvelle
phphilosophie, peut-êtrtre parce
OmOmicron est une nouvelle
réréalité, ce n'est plus la
lilimitation des contacts.
- - C'est de vivre avec eux.
- - Mêmeme le docteur vient de e
didire aussi. Luc, premier
cocommentaire mais annonce
d'd'aujourd'hui.
- - Moi, je pense que le
gogouvernement a pris la mesure
d'd'Omicron. N'a rien à v voir c
leles efforts qu'on a faits. C't
lala phrase qui a été choisie pr
MoMonsieur Legault. Dans les
fafaits, la santé publique se d:
onon est capable, compte tenu de
lala baisse des cas de la
popositivité, incapable de prene
cecertains risques. Par exemple,
lele fait de limiter les Allemas
àà c cinq jours. On sait que de
lilimiter les Allemands à c cinq
jojours, les gens vont revenir t
vovont êtrtre encore contagieuxt
ilils sont peu nombreux. Ce qui
vovont transmettre, c'est une
nonouvelle maladie qui est moins
dadangereuse que le Delta. On va
cocommencer à t travailler avecs
ririsques. Va commencer à a accr
dedes risques. Il y en a des
ririsques. Quand on regarde écos
sosont restées ouvertes, les
écécoles spécialisées sont rests
ououvertes pendant la semaine, l
y y a eu une désinfection de ces
écécoles tellement il y avait dx
cacas. École qui vous pour cent
d'd'élèveves 50 % d'élèveves. La
gagarderie, 26 % des cas
d'd'éclosion dans les garderie.a
y y avoir des risques, des cas,e
cocouronnement se dit que on va
vivivre avec ces cas.
- - Vous soulignez ou trois
chchangements de discours. Le 30
dédécembre, ce n'était pas Mila.
C'C'était le couvre-feu, c'était
épépouvantable. On a refermé pls
féféerique ailleurs au Canada.
D'D'ailleurs mêmeme en Occidente
cocouvre-feu, il n'y en avait ps
nunulle part. On dit que il faut
vivivre avec, il va se promenere
totoute façon. L'important, la
vavaccination. Le 30, on a été
trtrop sévèrere et là o on ne lt
papas assez?
cocomment réconcilier cela
StStéphanie?
- - C'est difficile d'avoir
exexactement le bon timing pour
inintervenir, mais c'est vrai
ququ'il y a eu un peu de
réréservation. Défendant
l'l'impression que on avance, on
rerecule. Effectivement, il y an
chchangement de paradoxe en ce
momoment. Plusieurs médecins l't
didit. En ce moment, on devrait
apapprendre à v vivre. Omicron,e
n'n'est pas la mêmeme bibitte qe
DeDelta. On doit agir
didifféremment. Je pense qu'on t
rerendu là. . Je note, c'est quy
a a eu des bonnes nouvelles aux
popoints de presse. Il y a moins
d'd'absence. Au lieu de 20 000,l
y y a 15 000 absences dans le
réréseau de la santé. Ce n'est s
ququelque chose négligeable.
EsEspérons qu'on puisse avec les
memesures qui ont été annoncées,
alaller chercher du personnel et
dédésengorger les hôpipitaux.
- - On voit que Monsieur Legauly
titient à r rendre la vie plus
didifficile, à e encourager le s
popossible les noms vaccinés à e
fafaire vacciner. Les grandes
susurfaces, ça va peut-êtrtre ps
efefficace qu'une éventuelle ta.
MiMichèlele et Luc, qu'avez-vous
pepensé de cette nouvelle
ofoffensive pour convaincre les
gegens de se faire vacciner. Vos
nene pourrez plus aller au Cost,
WaWalmart, aux Canadiennes Tire.
- - Le mêmeme jour que l'OMS di:
atattention, la vaccination ne
sesera pas la seule solution.
QuQuestion de l'efficacité de
dodoses contre Omicron.
L'L'efficacité qui disparaîtrtr,
réréduirait un espace assez cou,
unune dizaine de semaines,
popossibilité de nouveaux varias
auaussi. On part de la
vavaccination, c'est important.
VaVaccination, tout le monde dot
êêtrtre vacciné. Mais il faut
cocommencer à p penser, si on vt
vivivre avec les virus qui s'en
viviennent, un qui va dépasser
OmOmicron, faut commencer à p pr
quque ce ne peut pas êtrtre la e
sosolution. J'ai l'impression qe
cecette idée de s'en prendre aux
nonoms vaccinés et une question
dede, pour satisfaire la
popopulation, pour établir une
esespècece de chaînene de solidé
enen disant: on doit tous faire
faface. En termes de ce que c'et
jujuste ça que nous permettre de
lului et contre les vagues de
vivivre qui s'en viennent, pas
cecertain.
- - Michel?
c'c'est santé publique ou
popolitique?
- - je pense que c'est tout ça n
mmêmeme temps. C'est sociologiqe
auaussi. Oui, il y a une
frfrustration évidente envers ls
nonoms vaccinés, bien honnêtete,
jeje ne pense pas qu'on puisse
rerendre tous ces gens
reresponsables de la situation
dadans laquelle on est. Ça n'aie
papas, mais c'est probablement s
lele principal facteur. La hause
dedevient important, c'est que i
leles vaccinés se disent nous, n
a a fait des efforts. Eux, ils
n'n'en font pas. Ça ne veut pasa
pepeine d'en faire on n'en fera
papas non plus. Le problèmeme ct
dadavantage de voir les
trtraitements qui a déjà c comm.
LeLes traitements à l l'adhésiox
memesures sanitaires qu'on obsee
dadans les sondages. Les gens se
didisent: écouter n'est pas
dadavantage à l les suivre, on t
totous dans le mêmeme bateau. Ct
bebeaucoup plus de mesure qui ve
àà s susciter l'adhésion qu'à
prprévenir de nouvelles éclosio.
- - Stéphanie, d'empêchcher less
vavaccinales dans les grandes
susurfaces, une idée ou pas?
- - je pense que on était rendu
llà. . C'est sûr r qu'il vaut my
alaller par étapes qu'il arrivat
avavec des armes comme la
cocontribution d'un coup sec. Si
onon peut prendre des petits pa,
etet dire: c'est ça règlgle le
prproblèmeme, tant mieux. Moi, e
pepense que c'est une bonne idé.
SiSi on peut réduire les contacs
dadans les grandes surfaces, pae
quque moi, je me dis qu'il y a n
papacte social de dire : besoine
lala vaccination, ceux qui n'y
adadhèrerent pas, la moindre des
chchoses qu'ils restent chez eux
pupuisqu'ils essaient de ne pas
cocontaminer, de ne pas répondre
lala maladie. Je pense que oui,
c'c'est tout à f fait sensé.
- - Très s bien, les noms vaccis
sosont répartis partout au Québ.
IlIl n'y aura pas de
cicirconscription unique va faie
gagagner par exemple, je m'en vs
auau sondage a été publié
l'l'actualité qui va faire gagnr
lele parti conservateur. On dit
ququ'il y a une baisse. Oui il a
unune baisse. Quand toutes pour
cecent, ben pour les libéraux, 9
popour Québec solidaire qui a ft
unun bond appréciable. Le parti
coconservateur qui monte, 13 %
plplus Parti québécois qui fermt
lala marche à 1 10 %. Il y a une
babaisse, mais nommez-moi notre
prpremier ministre ou un présidt
enen Occident qui a une telle
avavance après s deux ans de
papandémie. Il n'y en a pas
bebeaucoup Michel David :
- - non, c'est un bon score. Le
scscore évitement de la dernière
élélection pour la CAQ. Je pense
quque c'est assez circonstancie.
EnEntre le dernier sondage qu'on
avavait eu de léger, qui était u
dédébut de décembre, on était à
4646. Là, , on est rendu à 3 30à
papart la pandémie la frustratin
quque les mesures ont engendrée.
IlIl n'y a pas grand-chose dans
l'l'actualité qui a pu provoquer
unun tel mouvement d'opinion. Si
dadans trois ou quatre mois la
cacampagne virale le climat
s's'améliore, et Monsieur Legaut
lele sang aussi, je pense vous
dodonner un peu d'électorat, du
ccôtété de la CAQ. Ce serait pae
quque le parti conservateur du
QuQuébec, une fois que toutes ls
ininstructions ne seront plus
auaussi frustrantes, se
mamaintiennent à c ce score. Pe-
êêtrtre, on verra. Je prends ce
sosondage la comme l'état de
l'l'union actuelle qui est anné.
LaLa lassitude. Ce n'est pas une
ququêtete de ce que sera la
prprochaine réduction.
- - Luc.
- - Monsieur Legault a besoin
d'd'une victoire sur la Kovy :
paparce que ce n'est pas de la
fafatigue, c'est pas une défait,
onon retourne à l la case zéro.n
pepensait qu'on sortait, on
pepensait que c'était fini, on a
pepensé deux fois d'ailleurs, et
llà o on voit, on remarque.
S'S'il n'a pas cette victoire,
MoMonsieur Legault va êtrtre trs
rarapide attention mais cette
vivictoire en résultats
pepersonnels. C'est grâcece aux
efefforts que nous avons faits,
quque nous avons mis nous avonsu
cecette victoire. Je pense que a
popourrait avovoir un impact sue
vovote. Mais comme le dit Monsir
DaDavid, on est au mêmeme niveae
àà l la dernièrere élection. C't
ququoi, 30, ça?
mamaintenant, on est  à 3 38 : c
sosolidaire était à 1 16 quelque
chchose hélas à 1 19. Il n'y a s
dede grande inquiétude pour
MoMonsieur Legault, mais quand
mmêmeme, il a besoin de cette
vivictoire. De la victoire conte
lala COVID.
- - Je pense que le début de la
papandémie, c'était assez
fafantastique pour Monsieur
LeLegault. Marche pratiquement r
l'l'eau. La peut-êtrtre un peu u
dadans ses chaussures, est-ce qe
soson score est quand mêmeme
exextrêmemement enviable. Ça fet
babaver d'envie Jason Kenney. O,
évévidemment, les gens, avec la
cicinquièmeme vague, il y a une
fafatigue. On pensait que était
sosorti, et on réalise qu'on a
enencore droit à u un autre toue
mamanègege. Tout le monde s'en
seserait passé. Il y a deux ansà
pepeu près s chaque famille. Çad
lala situation encore plus
coconcrètete que les vagues
prprécédentes où les victimes
ététaient plus éloignées. Quand
totout le monde a des cas dans n
enentourage, ça joue sur le mor.
OnOn a tendance à s se bouc
émémissaire, des coupables. Ce
n'n'est pas surprenant que le
gogouvernement perde un peu de
plplume.
- - Et ce qui devrait s'acquittr
dede ce sondage, c'est des
lilibéraux et les péquistes. Ne
prprofite pas du mécontentement.
CÇa va soit Québec solidaire ou
coconservateur. Les deux vieux
papartis font du surplace.